Haley thank you for being with us the
first thing I have to ask you is if this
morning after Jed's moments on the live
show Tuesday night are you feeling a
little vindicated
I feel like Oh sense of release you know
the pressures off everything is out
there everything instead said you know I
knew from the very beginning I'm being
honest and so they're on both sides so
now it's very me a great pleasure last
time we talked you told me you were not
watching the show did you start watching
it since then and did you watch the
finales synopsis and sort of what he had
said but I guess I didn't really be able
to eat just gave Burma well Haley I want
to read you a couple of quotes from Jed
because it was quite shocking to watch
some of the things that he was saying to
Hannah Hannah confronted him about you
guys's relationship and Jed said quote I
didn't feel like it was an exclusive
thing I was dating around I was never
like this is my girlfriend yes I was
hooking up with other girls
it's news to me I mean you know I have
found out during the filming of this
show and you know post their engagement
you know that is when I started finding
out that other women were involved even
while we were in a relationship and you
know call me naive but you know from my
perspective I'm believing in someone and
trusting someone that's saying that
they're falling in love with me and
they're saying I love yous and perhaps
I'm off base here but you know I love
you to me these I love you not I'm
seeing a bunch of other people so you
know well he said that he had been
drinking when he told you that he loved
you every time it's an excellent point
in Haley I wondered yeah I would imagine
he said it to you more than once and I'm
more than one different day he said it
more than once on March 12 today that he
left for filming so that's just okay and
was that universe tiny say I love you
absolutely not so so he definitely
wasn't it would seem drunk every single
time he said I love you during a
relationship definitely not he also said
that the only reason he went on trips
with you were because he quote got a
cabin for free and I was kind of shocked
he brought your family into it he said
well I only went on a trip with her
because her parents gave me a vacation
for my birthday
and what monsters they must be to have
you know but have have just met him you
know three weeks prior to his birthday
you know and we're talking about
and beyond that I put in some of that
cost and they just helped to help out
because we went on my birthday so I mean
it's a little hurtful to me that you
know you've you've just met my family
and now we're gonna and you know call me
a monster for throwing a surprise party
for the person that is telling you this
falling in love with me and you know
doing the things that you do in a
relationship yeah you know maybe maybe
I'm off-base or missing in I wonder what
a relationship is that to me you know
and beyond that if we want to go ahead
and talk about a free cabin we split the
cost for the cabin so I wasn't even
forever so it was a lie that it was free
yeah okay I mean did you guys call each
other boyfriend and girlfriend and did
your friends know you two as a couple
yes so I mean we're in Nashville where
you know and the crazy thing is even
since all this came out I've had so many
people that are like you know we knew
about you we hung out with your writers
rounds you know we thought that it was
YouTube it's the world so it's kind of
like it's hard from multiple times like
I knew that it was gonna come out the
further I got along I'm like everybody
knows about this so I'm confused yeah it
wasn't some kind of secret it's
interesting that you just said it was
you two against the world because in one
of the finale
so it's just said something similar like
that day yeah he said only you and I
know what we have and he was kind of
going against the fact that her parents
didn't really seem to like him did Jed
encourage that thinking with you that it
was you two against everybody else and
you were in it together just the two of
you I mean you know the whole premise
had me been going on this show kind of
set a precedent from the beginning of
our relationship that it was kind of we
kind of had to have this like secretive
ish kind of relationship you know we
can't post on social media because this
is an opportunity way so therefore you
know I I bought into that as well I
believed in this person and I was down
to be named you against the world
so it's you know I kind of understand
probably her mindset as well and where
she's thinking some hand I want this
person it's maybe it sounds like from
what you're saying Jed was telling him
multiple lies even when she confronted
him with the knowledge that you two had
been in a relationship at least you know
lies and just thing of everything we
haven't bang he was drunk when he said I
love you saying that you two were not
exclusive just honestly I just and once
again I definitely hit the high points
of all these notes and I heard from my
mom and sister who met them and loved
him and you know
believed in him as well and were by my
side so it's like yeah that really so
the last time you and I talked you said
that you still believe Jed was a good
person do you think that Jed is a good
guy is this the Jed that you knew seeing
the apparent lies he continued to tell
Hannah I mean this is where I kind of
like there's this disconnect for me
because I fell in love with this person
who told me that they loved me and then
now I'm kind of on the backside of this
thinking how did I how did I miss this
who who is this person that I'm now
seeing on my TV screen it's just like a
weird disconnect I can't even he's a bad
person and I truly believe that good
people do bad things but I'm just like
missing kind of yeah the image like I'm
kind of missing how it could how we can
be here honestly it's interesting Lee
because Hanna said that same thing she
said this person me and Jed here in
front of her is not the person I got
engaged - she said they seemed like two
different people and they actually
interviewed Hanna just an hour ago and I
asked her she had a message for you and
she did I just wanted to read it to you
she said that I've been in a similar
situation in the past before and from
this she's learned a lot just like I
have and a she knows her Worth and what
she deserves and I hope that she can
find someone that truly makes her happy
one day
it's incredible because I wish the same
for her I just I can't you know the
biggest regret that I've had in all of
this is that this was her experience
this was her love story and you know my
being sort of the other woman in this
you know scenario is what caused her
heartbreak at the end of this thing that
was supposed to be so incredible for her
so I just I wish all the happiness all
the best things to come out of this for
her and I have most definitely learned
from every moment of this and I know she
wants you so I
that's incredible thank you for sharing
that do you think Jed has really learned
he apologized to Hanna
he said he owns things do you think he's
really learned from this and really will
change I hope so
I mean it's like I said of me that good
people do bad things and I think you
know sometimes maybe it takes somebody
just shaking you to say this isn't okay
so I hope that this is maybe that that
moment and there were moments on social
media last night some people were saying
his his roommates were instagramming
pictures of t-shirts they'd made that
said like things like Jed is free now
knowing some of the same people in
Nashville do you think that his friends
are supporting him to become better do
you think he really wants to be better
just from what you've heard from your
circles you know I really hope so and
that is kind of where it's like this
rock and a hard place churning
you know I know these guys I know his
roommates sat on their couch and watched
football with them many time you know so
it's it's hard for me to think I have to
kind of believe that maybe they just
don't understand the magnitude of what
has happens and that they're just
thinking about their buddy but you know
they wanted to come out and hang out and
I understand that they
have a stacking you know I appreciate
that I don't want to be a lot of friends
you know I don't want to feel alone but
at the same time like I think maybe
they're missing the point of you know an
engagement was ended and a heart was
broken to three hearts you know I think
maybe they're just like missing the real
life point of what has happened here
well Hannah told Jed that she had heard
he had women over to his house even
after they were engaged that he was
throwing women in his pool that kind of
thing
had you heard about things like that and
about him apparently telling people he
wanted at the show I mean there were
definitely little rumors like going
around town that nothing that I had like
concrete proof or had seen I didn't see
any like messages or pictures or
anything so and a lot even then I was
like I want to believe that if they got
engaged that it's you know I said a lot
of interviews like I want to believe
that it's real and that it's right so
you know and I tried for the most part
to just be in a state of like okay I
have to move on from this and not worry
about what he's now doing it nationally
so well you told me that you had never
heard from Jed again since sending him
off to the show with the thought that he
was going to come back to you you even
gave him your guitar case have you heard
from him since and have you gotten the
guitar case back no no but you know I
could really say in the face a friend
zipper I mean
so he still never given you a call what
would you want to hear from him would
you want him to call it and give you an
apology
at this point I I mean I would like to
know I guess that there's some kind of
remorse I don't know that I will ever
get it is at this point I think so much
damage has been done
and I just it's not even at this point
it's not even necessary I'm I've moved
on from him and you know the last night
was kind of the last moment of all the
craziness so it's you know I can just
kind of go on with my life now a lot of
people were talking during Jays hometown
about his family's reaction to him and
Hannah because they seemed so shocked
they kept saying this was so crazy and
people wondered well in their minds are
they thinking we thought you had a
girlfriend do you think and I'm deeply
under the impression that Jays parents
knew about you two staying together
while you were on the show did you see
any of that footage and what did you
think of their reactions I mean it was
tough because this is one of those
things you know I spent five days of his
family and so and time and talked to
them while he was going so if these are
people that you know I kind of formed a
relationship with and care about so it's
you know that has also been like a hard
thing in all this about them an either
son and they have to love him but for
sure you know I saw foot so that episode
and I'm wondering kind of the same thing
like you know yeah we had breakfast
together know that Jed intended to go on
the show and come back and continue
dating you yes I mean basically the
night before he left it was you know
praying through you Haley and you know
we know this isn't easy for you so if
you talk to them late
now and and I would never you know
expecting they never want to be in the
middle of it in fact you know I'd say
one of the hardest things is knowing
that they're most definitely reading the
comments and tweets and things and all
the negative things everything said
about him and I can't imagine being in
their shoes if that was my you know
sibling or my son I can't imagine you
know what they're feeling so you don't
know that stuff do you think that Jed
truly loved Hanna and truly wanted to
marry her I hope so do you think you
know ready for marriage I think you know
here's the part where I believe this was
a little bit selfish if you love someone
the goal is the whole idea of loving
someone is putting them before yourself
and this was her experience she had
every opportunity to be with one of you
know these other great guys or or at
least who have made the decision for
herself if she was okay with the
situation that she was in she didn't
even get that option which I think you
know that's not really fair when you
love someone to be honest there are
seemingly been a lot of Lies from Jed
Haley which lie bothers you the most I
would say you know the downplaying of
and really like I said I didn't watch
that just hearing about his saying that
we just ran by his family's house and
it's just a free cabin and he only went
because you know it's just downplaying
all of these things that meant a lot to
me
and I just believe when somebody says I
love you call me crazy for believing in
that you know and so it's just
kind of like she liked the okay so now
you're saying none of that meant
anything to you and you're just do and I
do you think I mean he was telling you I
love you when do you think his feelings
did change in this process I have
wondered every single day you know I
when did you forget about me when did
you was it day one and you got there
anywhere just like actually didn't care
that much or was it you know when they
start traveling or two dates in and he
realizes she's you know and I don't know
but i have wondered every day you know
well the original plan was for him to go
on for his career and he's saying
multiple times he played the piano he
played the guitar Haley he sang during
the proposal did Jed get the career
exposure he was hoping for
he got exposure that is serving what do
you think of Jed's songwriting and
singing skills there's been a lot of
criticism you know as an artist you are
setting yourself up at all points in
time for criticism I am not even you
know I wasn't even in the shoes that
he's in and I get criticism so even
though as a fellow artist to read those
things I can't imagine how unbelievably
hurtful that is to hear and it's kind of
this is the moment when you have to say
I either push through this and I believe
in in my art enough to keep doing it or
you say do I want enough to overcome
this criticism and the things that
people are saying about me you know were
you surprised though that he's saying
during the proposal yeah that's
yeah yeah I was surprised I said he's
walking out of it get out of the car
with a car okay ah I Lisi left the case
you know at home I was like we got to
get you that case back hailey you still
want to add whitening all right I want
to rap with you you're hailey but I know
as you said you know you are
this artist singer-songwriter yourself
and I would imagine you've been given a
fair amount of material over the past
couple months tell us what's happening
next for your music so sweetly is my duo
we're very excited we're releasing a
single on not a jingle but a single on
Friday
actually it's already naked you can
pre-order it right now it has nothing to
do with any of this drama it's just a
fun summer song and we're just we're so
excited to give get moving with that and
kind of leave this an asset you need
your summer to turn fun it's time will
there be any songs about what you've
been through
yes you better follow along if I know
you just don't send jingle is that a
reference to Jed's dog food jingle I
just slip it something I you didn't help
me work on that did you or did you no
okay
yeah I guess I'll just ask you you know
one more time what was it like for you
to kind of wake up this morning and know
that everybody has seen
some of the realities of Jen's lies that
you had experienced for themselves
honestly it was just a release - you
know I kind of dreaded this night
because I just kind of knew in my gut
that it probably wasn't gonna be just an
ownership you know approach and but to
kind of at least every truth that I told
it was honest from the beginning at
least every single thing that I said was
exposed you know on both sides and now
everything's out there and this was the
ends of the line for this chapter so I'm
very thankful to be close in any message
you'd have - Jen now man please just we
have all learned from this we have all
made mistakes I can't say that I didn't
in this and you know I just I really
hope that all of us are able to learn
from this and and you take this and be
better than the next relationship that
were in all right Haley thank you so
much we really appreciate you I know
you've been through a lot and thank you
for staying strong through all of it so
thank you so much absolutely thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]